um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why
well if you want to be just
entertained
uh
i'm very proud of the first taken movie
i thought the three i did were good but
the first one i i particularly liked if
you want to be just entertained
historically uh i would go for michael
collins who was a parish revolutionary
leader one of the co-founders of the
modern irish republic
schindler's list of course which was a
quite a phenomenal film that steven
spielberg made and i was
honored to be a part of that um
but i've uh
just before christmas i finished my
100th film i got a chance to play
raymond chandler's classic
p.i phillip marlowe
again with neil jordan who directed
rhoden directed michael collins
so i hope i hope there's a flavor in
there
of different things throughout these 100
films which include documentaries by the
way that i now read it
which i i still love doing
um
but at the end of the day it's
entertainment isn't it i love going into
a cinema
from when i was a child
speaking maddening movies body murphy
westerns for example it was my hero as
the kid
[Music]
i i can't wait for us all to get back
into theaters again cinemas i completely
agree and by the way i am incredibly
excited that you paired up again with
neil jordan mostly because
uh i know william monahan wrote the
script and i'm a big fan of william
monahan's writing wonderful writer
absolutely i should have mentioned that
yes you're right delves getting into
blacklight um i i know you're offered a
lot of scripts what was it about this
one that said i want to play this
character
um it was a chance to work with mark
williams again
he was one of the cool writers and
directed it
we've done three films together
it was a chance to work with my old pal
aidan quinn
who plays my fbi boss and i like the
script because it had
you know yes there's thrills and spills
and there's action and stuff in it but
it put it it hints at
uncheckered
uh
power in government
uh
it investigates that in a very
interesting way i think
that we can apply to our own lives
nowadays
um
so it sort of so it gave certain levels
to the story
that uh max certainly my character
questioned
his existence his working existence over
the past 20 years you know
so it's always interesting to
or i try and put in a couple of extra
layers of something and these characters
you know
that hopefully comes across as a you
know
that there's some kind of sensitivity
there you know
mixed with
being able to buy somebody's brain so
you know
but this is why i like watching you work
and why you have so many fans it's
because you do do that um i am curious
though you've done you've worked on as
you said like a hundred films and i
would imagine that when you're working
with a director for the first time
especially a younger director have you
noticed that they're a little bit
nervous to actually give you direction
can you sort of talk about those first
few days on set where you're like
feeling each other out um if it is a
young director and he's fairly new or
she's fairly new i wish there were more
she's actually
but
i just trying to be i try to be
as prepared as possible and also to be
incredibly relaxed and not have an
attitude you know i can't stand that
actors actors sometimes of attitudes you
know what i mean
yes wait don't come near me i'm in
character
i'm not
i'm not really a fan of that i just try
and be
um
sociable
um but when that camera turns you know
we have a job to do and i like to
execute that as best as i possibly can
and if i can help the director in any
way i'll
maybe offer a couple of suggestions
but but they're
the young directors i've worked with
over the years they they're very very
good
this this new breed of directors are
coming up and they
they're uh
they're excellent they really are so i
always learn a lot from them you know on
that note i need to stop i'm just going
to say thank you for talking with me i'm
really looking forward to talking to you
about marlow
thank you me too yeah bill gold
writer oh i um i i'm a huge fan thank
you so much
you